[Music]
it was urgent to first establish a
diagnosis a diagnosis on the
new nas and the attacks against
European democracies attacks which
are fomented by hostile foreign states
these attacks that they are of
various natures c  It's cyber
attacks against our institutions It
's disinformation campaigns on
platforms It's the capture of
elites It's also the financing of
political parties and political campaigns
that aim to undermine our
institutions from abroad
thanks to  the voice of the ning commission and
the european parliament have made an
extraordinary it will pass in timid
significant rise sounded the hallali
you can be very cult of the
enlisted coach samurai zynga of finding in
the gossip to end problems at
witch's platform
[Music]
the  cow boys regulating
platform year
[Music]
our abyane lab date habitat
wait and audition various
occasions and dean against el  kouni moman
who goes up to the color party and to
tell you is that are our min choral parties
and the cakes to the mines and
through what is the activities and to
our network by grace and the note
the commission
the national front displays a
position to Russians for a long time
since the breakup of the ussr, but at the
time of these loans of its financing,
lobbying intensified
quite spectacularly
, which was concretely illustrated by
a defense of Russian interests
through declarations  public
propaganda videos of the votes for
example paul the association agreement
with ukraine where or against the report on the
anti european union propaganda of the
kremlin
so we can always try to
discuss the tibet of taiwan of the uigours
of hong kong of  the situation of
migrant workers but only in
the terms of the communist party and the
best thing is not to talk about it at all
to our
[Music]
country
regains its legs every
political groups and of all the countries which,
once their career is over but just two
seconds later, will sign fabulous contracts
with companies which
are the armed wing of regimes hostile to
our principles and our interests and therefore
we will have to put an end to  this
great betrayal of the elites
harmonize electoral laws and
prohibit foreign funding
for political parties and formations
track down citizens who are names and shell
companies investing massively
in our cyber security and
sanction much more harshly the
states that coordinate attacks against
our institutions impose
responsibilities to
digital platforms building a
lasting system for protecting the
European information space let's do it quickly
we have to do more money
weekend
of tf1 after its forms available
to good my father you don't bring awa
doumbia mo farah multistrada father
continue to  phase 6 which places them in
europe  and and and single i started national
here efficacy remember monkfish
at term interference supports
contrasts of uniforms said in chains
the hot part i was out retail
match glad we can continue
our work to defend
european democracies  in particular
in view of the
2024 elections concern for interference it is by an
ephemeral phenomenon it will be a
continuous low intensity war and it was
important not that the European parliament
say to itself it is good we took care of it and
then  the subject disappears in the
various committees, we have to
manage to keep our attention
focused on this problem and that
we ensure that
European citizens go to vote in 2024
in conditions of serenity and
security that it  mine of the specter
democracy
sousse tap of the specters nda hamcho a
trophy
[Music]
[Applause]